hey guys i'm ryan right so today what
I'm gonna be doing is counting down my
top 10 favorite summer movie
blockbusters reason why summers coming
to an end so I thought I'd share some of
the best blockbusters actually alright
so number 10 for me has to be Minority
Report this film is one of the best
futuristic sci-fi thrillers I've ever
seen it takes its time but it's intense
it's thought-provoking the film is full
of imagination with dark high concept
ideas there's awesome action some of the
most memorable sci-fi sequences I've
ever seen there's like this awesome
sense of like film noir and it certainly
features one of my favorite Tom Cruise
performances and for those of you who
haven't seen it in our worried don't
worry he does run in the film number
nine for me has to be dawn of the Planet
of the Apes this is like one of the more
serious blockbusters minor reports very
seriously this is another serious one
but it's very entertaining still the
filmmakers managed to bring this really
emotionally captivating story told
through realistic-looking CG iep's oops
there's powerful motion capture
performances there's intense action
sequences this is one of those films
that really works because the actors
really believe what's going on in this
world number 8 has to be Jurassic Park
so much could be said about this film my
parents took me to watch it when I was
three years old thanks for the trauma
but beyond my trauma it's emotionally
moving full of wonder and awe and
there's like interesting debates about
bringing dinosaurs back to life then it
like tap way through turns into like
this monster or picture it's certainly
one of the spill Birds best films now I
truly love this [ __ ] movie man t-rex
more like pee Rex it's like all little
red number seven for me back to the
future to me this movie truly stands the
test of time it's incredibly inventive
hilarious hey you get your damn hands
off of her Crispin Glover man he's
[ __ ] creepy it has a wonderful energy
in life it features two of the most
memorable performances in cinema Marty
McFly Doc Brown hands down one of the
most entertain
time travel films you will ever see
inglourious basterds each and every one
of you here owes me 100 nazi scalps and
I want my scams this film is interesting
because its historical fiction but it
manages to stay true to the tone and the
atmosphere of what world war two was
like yet Tarantino adds a rather unique
kick-ass twist to it Tarantino's written
a lot of great villains this one is my
favorite villain that he's ever ridden
or wrote I don't know English it's one
of the more entertaining period pictures
and it's also one of the best probably
the best historical fiction piece I've
ever seen number five has to be edge of
tomorrow I talked plenty about this
movie over the past year its hands down
one of the most entertaining and
inventive sci-fi films I've ever seen
there's a surprising amount of humor Tom
Cruise he's pretty funny he's pretty
funniest intelligence as a funny sense
of you Emily Blunt kicks serious ass
I'll be blunt I would do things to that
serious ass oh the effects and action
are awesome the intense thrills are felt
literally you live yet die and then you
repeat it on your blu-ray huh that was
good before Pirates of the Caribbean Oh
name is Kevin chicks man where did all
the rum go without a doubt this movie
was one of the most magical times I've
ever had at the theaters whose
surprisingly thrilling wonderful set
designs really memorable music and one
of the most amazing / worst things to
happen in cinematic history Jack Sparrow
humor the first time you watch captain
jack sparrow I was [ __ ] magical man
now it's number three the Dark Knight my
father
drink where is he well he must have
friends my awesome impressions and the
fact that I saw this film eight times in
the theaters six of those times on imax
i think it's enough to tell you how good
it is number two marvel's the avengers
one of the most impressive films i've
ever seen this film had a lot of
anticipation but there's also a lot of
concern could they really pull off a
film that this much of a crossover film
and give all these characters equal
treatment and still make it a really
good entertaining time it ended up being
one of the greatest summer blockbusters
I was laughing throughout I just had a
big smile on my face the action was
[ __ ] awesome the amped up their
powers it solidified the Marvel
Cinematic Universe now that's just more
than cinematic history that's just real
history number one for me has to be
Terminator 2 a Judgment Day get to the
choppa that's not from terminate or two
but that's the only art online I know
how to say and also come on me if you
want to live none of the shitty sequels
can ruin this film for me this to me is
the greatest summer movie of all time it
has great character memorable action
sequences that still to this day stand
out those groundbreaking visuals visuals
that still look awesome today James
Cameron took the t800 one of the most
memorable villains in history and then
he made him one of the greatest heroes
in cinematic history it's a dark
menacing sci-fi action thriller but by
the end of the film most people [ __ ]
cry I know I did anyway guys that's my
top 10 list if you are not happy with it
because your movie wasn't on there well
guess what movies are opinion based and
this is my [ __ ] opinion so if you
really want to say some [ __ ] just
you know [ __ ] your mom have trauma /
[ __ ] your mom and then hang yourself
for feeling shameful I might have been a
little too dark for this video anyway
guys if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects you
can follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter vine and periscope because if we
get enough followers we can get even
more prominent placement I'm not getting
a product placement from religions I
think religions could really sponsor me
christians buddhists hindus Jews the
Jews don't like me I don't know why